[Music]
you know I wake up every morning my
first thought is what part of me is not
working today and we have passengers on
boat slowly sinking your boat is slow
I'm like when the Titanic was pointing
up so how's your love life you're still
seeing uh what's-her-name Triscuit
Tristan and know all this bad she was
kind of cute
oh we have much to talk about you know
she was half my age half your age is
still an old woman that human through
the mess never visitor oh sandy hey
kiddo
listen when I'm gone I check look after
Norman me yeah his best friend right I
don't know am I know but don't argue
with her you got it listen to me we're
all scared because it's a scary [ __ ]
world but we get through it because
we're not alone me you dumb [ __ ] come on
dummy you're just depressed it'll pass
it'll pass
my job doesn't fulfill me anymore and I
just put my 45 year old daughter in
rehab just keep going you know you're
not the only one here with problems Oh
what are your problems you sing this
nice Lisa woman I mean are you crazy
about me you amuse me
I'll take it you have a thriving
business a wonderful loving daughter
wait you've been bathroom again
what's wrong nothing's wrong I think
something's going on with this prostate
[Music]
it hurts to be human it hurts like hell
and all the exploring in the world
doesn't make that hurt go away because
being human and being hurt or the same
damn thing how was your day I had a
strange little man stick his finger up
my ass you complete me I envy you
[Music]